the other big story this week obviously
was the Durham report coming out let's
just dive into it real quick daily wire
special counselor John Durham who was
tasked by former Attorney General Bill
Barr to examine the propriety of the
FBI's investigation of President Trump
released a 320-page report on Monday
that found the FBI had no evidence to
support a trump-russia scandal when it
began its investigation and found
sobering differences in how it
approached the Trump probe compared to
other politically sensitive
investigations
Pedro am I some sort of uh genius or
person from the future in that I never
fell for this thing and people could go
back to all of my videos for the past
six years and never find me buying what
obviously was completely nonsensical
yeah no and honestly it's interesting
because this this should be something
that is like really sort of shocking but
it's not for exactly that reason it's
like this is not really news and I think
that's why there was there was this I
think the maybe again I didn't see all
of it but it that's the impression I got
from the reaction to it was it was just
kind of people you know sighing like
yeah we knew that
um but I guess the the reason I haven't
really gotten kind of you know in uh
upset about it I guess is because I I
don't want to just get angry about this
about this attempt by the Deep state to
do whatever I I actually want
accountability and I think there's a
problem now and this is kind of an
outsider take on this issue but the the
problem on the right is that we I think
we like just getting really angry about
things and then never holding anybody
accountable or getting serious enough to
hold people accountable and that's kind
of where I'm at it's like yes of course
they did this of course it was wrong and
unethical and horrible but now what
I I don't want to just get angry about
it I'm not going to wait for big
structural changes I would love to see
obviously accountability on a bigger
level
um but on a smaller level I want
everybody who fell for these hoaxes
every time that they say anything I want
us to say you thought Donald Trump was a
Russian spy so just disqualify all of
their future opinions that's what they
do to us that's why Media Matters exist
and so we they catch us saying something
that's like wrong or inappropriate or
whatever and then they use that line to
disqualify everything that we say going
forward I don't see why we don't do that
to them have the list of people who said
absolutely insane things about Donald
Trump's connection to Russia and hold
them accountable like that for the rest
of their lives
so the other thing that happened this
weekend it's sort of related to that is
there was a congressional hearing on the
weaponization of government and a couple
FBI whistleblowers have come out and
what we're going to play for you right
now is unbelievably extraordinary and
again the question is will anything
happen uh basically a whistleblower
saying yeah we can't release all the all
those tapes the Tucker got because we
were pretty much in on it take a look
those individuals were inside the
capitol to which the SSA responded back
and I was privy to these conversations
firsthand why can't you show us
why can't you just send us that give us
access to the 11 000 hours of video of
this exam that's available
because there may be maybe
uc's undercover officers or chs's
confidential unit for confidential human
sources on those videos whose identity
we need to protect oh hot damn it turns
out there were a whole bunch of
undercover FBI agents on top of the fact
that we saw police officers moving
barricades opening doors for people
welcoming welcoming them into the
capital